bis 9
vielen stefan vielen dank stephan kulle
für diese übergabe und ich kann ihn
vielleicht eines vorab versprechen der
praxis wird auch hier aus straßburg aus
sicht des europaparlaments in den blick
genommen
man hat sich ein bisschen festgelegt und
hat gesagt heute beginnen wir mit den
urheberrechten morgen dann der brh exit
also alles wird geliefert sozusagen zu
seiner zeit heute also wollen wir
sprechen über die reform des
urheberrechts über eine anpassung ans
internet-zeitalter ich bin sehr froh
dass zwei gäste zu uns gefunden haben
die tatsächlich experten sind auf diesem
gebiet und die den ganzen prozess mit
begleitet haben ich darf ganz herzlich
begrüßen sven schulze von der svp
fraktion erst dort unter anderem im
ausschuss im sozialausschuss aktiv aber
auch in anderen und ich darf herzlich
begrüßen martin schilde waren von der
linken-fraktion er ist auch
spitzenkandidat für seine partei und er
ist im wirtschafts und währungsausschuss
also stephan kohler siems angedeutet ist
tatsächlich ein bisschen schwierig es
ist kontrovers das internetzeitalter
erfordert eben anpassungen juristischer
seite
die eu kommission hat das angeregt 2016
hat man sich im februar 2009 10 nach
einem ziemlich langen prozess geeinigt
und ist jetzt an einer stufe angekommen
wo man nochmal letztlich debattieren und
abstimmen kann das ganze heute also im
europaparlament tatsächlich möchten wir
aber nochmal ein bisschen tiefer gehen
und noch mal die gns ist aufrufen herr
schulze wäre gern bei ihnen beginnen
das ist jetzt ein thema was fast nicht
mehr zumindest in deutschland
emotionsfrei besprochen werden kann wir
machen hier jetzt dennoch den versuch
wenn wir noch mal ganz klar sagen warum
braucht es jetzt diese novelle weil es
hier auch um das thema schutz des
geistigen eigentums im internet geht es
geht darum dass wir plattformen haben im
internet die inhalte nutzen die ihnen
nicht gehören damit aber sehr viel geld
verdienen das kreative die damit ihren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten müssen nicht
davon leben können wenn sie für ihre
inhalte für ihre für das was sie
erschaffen haben kein geld bekommen
nichts verdienen und da müssen wir
natürlich darauf reagieren und das wie
sie richtig gesagt haben ist kein
prozess der in den letzten wochen
passiert ist sondern das ist eine zeit
in den letzten
warm gewesen wo man sich hier über die
fraktion hinaus im rat auch in einer
kommission auf ein ergebnis verständigt
hat was wir heute hier im europäischen
parlament abstimmen wollen
also ein längerer prozess seit 2016
damals übrigens von eu kommissar für
digitales in dieser funktion günther
oettinger angeregt und auf dem weg
gebracht und ja auch ein prozess obwohl
ganz viele gruppen mitgespielt haben
über entscheidungsfindungen können wir
auch gleich noch sprechen martin schade
waren
wenn wir jetzt einfach mal uns das
angucken und sagen an welcher stelle
sehen wir den bedarf für veränderung was
genau muss verändert werden aus ihrer
perspektive
wir sind uns zunächst darin aber nicht
dass wir natürlich ein an das
internet-zeitalter angepasst das
urheberschutz recht brauchen
dass aber gleichzeitig gewährleistet
dass zum beispiel der freien
meinungsaustausch auch im internet
weiterhin erhalten bleibt und ich glaube
dass die jetzt vorliegende copyright
directive also das leistungsschutzrecht
was auf europäischer ebene verhandelt
worden ist in den letzten jahren beiden
ansprüchen noch nicht gerecht werden
kann
da gibt es ja einige ganz entscheidenden
knackpunkte die auch in der genese
intensiv diskutiert worden sind in der
europäischen gesellschaft in der
deutschen gesellschaft und ich glaube
wir müssen heute darüber entscheiden
inwieweit urheberrechte tatsächlich
geschützt werden können durch die
vorliegende urheberrechtsrichtlinie
leistungsschutz richtlinie ich sehe das
nicht und ich glaube wir müssen auch
darüber reden inwieweit das freie
internet verteidigt werden können und
ich sehe auch dass nicht gewährleistet
würden sie denn sagen dass zum aktuellen
zeitpunkt freie meinungsäußerung absolut
und eingeschränkt möglich ist an jeder
stelle der welt angeht ja an jeder
stelle der welt vielleicht nicht es ist
natürlich schwierig mit ja zu
beantworten aber das sind ja die
voraussetzung
aber was ist wo es gehen ja in der tat
aber was sie in der sache ansprechen ist
ja der artikel 11 ist es gut dass wir
nicht sofort bei artikel 13
den haben wir noch vor uns also artikel
11 leistungsschutzrecht für verleger
durch außen es geht um diese klippe ist
es geht darum so zu sagen was wird
herausgenommen wie weit ist das möglich
wie weit kann man da sozusagen ansetzen
und dafür etwas aufrufen dann die
verlage sind doch eigentlich stark genug
um sich das selber irgendwie mit den
plattformen zu einigen oder naja
wahrscheinlich also sagen wir haben von
vielen vielen verlegern rückmeldungen
bekommen in den letzten wochen noch mal
sehr intensiv die uns darin bestärken
dass wir hier ergebnisse brauchen das
ist also heute speziell nicht sein
darauf dass wir das was wir heute zur
abstimmung haben scheitern lassen und es
wurde angesprochen
es gibt sicherlich den ein oder anderen
technischen punkt noch über denen auch
in den letzten wochen sehr intensiv
diskutiert wurde
aber ich glaube dass es auf europäischer
ebene eine breite unterstützung dafür
gibt es sagte mein kollege der
linkspartei ja auch gerade dass wir hier
neue regeln brauchen dass wir hier auch
an das aktuelle zeitalter uns anpassen
müssen und dass am ende des tages auch
nicht nur die verlage sondern auch die
journalisten die dahinter stecken auch
eine faire vergütung bekommen dass wir
auch da uns entsprechend anders
zeitalter anpassen und das machen wir
hier mit ja und ich glaube was wir in
den letzten tagen erlebt haben auch in
deutschland was ich auch richtig und gut
fallen dass sich viele menschen mit der
thematik beschäftigt haben hat aber zu
kurz gegriffen wir haben uns immer nur
über ein thema unterhalten über die
technischen möglichkeiten gewisse dinge
vielleicht herauszufiltern
wahrscheinlich aber wir haben uns viel
zu wenig darüber unterhalten was wir
eigentlich damit wollen nämlich dass
lizenzen erworben werden
dass wir eine faire vergütung bekommen
auch im internet sowie das an anderer
stelle in der wirtschaft und in der
freien welt auch die zur verfügung steht
letzter prognose waren zur artikel 11
leistungsschutzrecht es gibt ja immer
verschiedene interessenträger die
verschieden groß sind und verschiedene
mächtig es gibt auch eine abgeordnete im
europäischen parlament von der
piratenpartei julia räder ja auch
sozusagen ganz stark vorne in dem
kreativen prozess mit drin war die
gesagt hat also das so wie das jetzt
geregelt wird oder geregelt werden soll
noch nicht abgestimmt in artikel 11 ist
das so dass es wiederum die kleinen
verlage benachteiligt auch ihre
auffassung
ja absolut dass meine auffassung also
wenn man auch da auf die genese noch mal
eingehen möchte wir wissen ja dass
2014 im letztem eine expertenkommission
im bundestag gesagt hat dass das
deutsche leistungsschutzrecht sowie es
existiert als gescheitert zu betrachten
ist weil eben insbesondere nur die
großen verlagshäuser oder die film und
musikindustrie davon profitiert haben
aber kleine mittelständische und start
ups stark benachteiligt worden sind was
mir mehr sorgen bereitet ist der artikel
der heute gerade frisch in der faz
erschienen ist wurde noch mal darauf
hingewiesen wird dass auch peter
altmaier so der deutsche
wirtschaftsminister offensichtlich die
interessen der kleinen und
mittelständischen und der start ups
zugunsten eines jetzt vorliegenden
leistungsschutzrechtes im interesse der
großen verlagshäuser fallen gelassen hat
das bereitet mir große sorgen was
überhaupt nicht geregelt ist in diesem
leistungsschutzrecht und da muss ich
ihnen widersprechen herr schulz sind die
interessen der journalistinnen und
journalisten weil zum beispiel so
unlautere vertragsverhältnis wie total
buy out klausel und so weiter und so
fort überhaupt nicht angegangen werden
das heißt wenn ein journalist ein stück
verkauft oder ein fotograf ist ein foto
oder ein grafiker seine grafik an einem
verlagshaus zur verfügung stellt
verliert damit sämtliche rechte und
solche unlauteren vertrags praxen sind
überhaupt nicht aufgehoben worden wären
überhaupt nicht angegangen da kann also
nicht davon die rede sein
das leistungsschutzrecht auch mit
urheberschutz harmonisiert wird darauf
reagieren also hat und haben andere da
sozusagen an anderer stelle zu weit
gegriffen
na ja das sehe ich nicht ganz so ich sag
mal zum einen ist es dann immer
wunderlich wenn die diskussionen jetzt
aufkommen wo die verhandlungen
abgeschlossen sind die bundesregierung
hat ja auch die möglichkeit gehabt im
rat entsprechend zu reagieren
sie hat dem ende zugestimmt die
spd-ministerin palais war der
verhandlungsführer führerinnen für die
deutsche bundesregierung und ich gebe
mit sicherheit all denjenigen recht die
sagen bei dem was wir heute beschließen
gibt es an der einen oder anderen stelle
noch verbesserungsbedarf
ja das haben wir bei fast jeder thematik
die wir hier haben wir sind nirgends so
dass wir alles abschließend verhandelt
haben und sagen da muss nie wieder was
dran gemacht wir haben das nicht aber
fakt ist und das sagen wir auch
journalisten kollegen die sagen wir
müssen jetzt hier erstmal beginnen
wir müssen jetzt hier das auch
beschließen damit am ende des tages
überhaupt was auf dem tisch liegt wenn
wir das heute nicht beschließen
dann haben wir im wesentlichen für viele
viele bereiche ja nichts neues
geschaffen und wir haben eine situation
die sich nicht verändert zu dem was wir
bisher und zu dem was wir bisher hatten
gab es der gründe warum wir das geändert
haben wollen und das nicht erst seit
heute schon sondern seit einigen jahren
hier diskutiert wird
ja okay die sache ist in bewegung sie
aber im grunde genommen gerade so was
wie das struktur gesetzt was wir aus
deutschland kennen das nicht so raus
geht wie es reingekommen ist ins
parlament und wir sind jetzt auch so
ganz zart jetzt doch bei artikel 13
gelandet
wenn wir jetzt mal ohne quasi in den in
den in der tat direkt einzusteigen aber
wenn wir einfach mal drauf sicht sagen
in der beobachtung dessen was wir in den
vergangenen monaten erlebt haben
auf der straße und auch im netz erinnert
das sehr stark an sozusagen diese
glaubenskrieg hafte situation die wir
bei tipp schon mal hatten
ist das wirklich angemessen der sache
herr schröder waren weil ich würde nicht
von glaubenskrieg sprechen sondern er
davon dass ich hier die europäische
bevölkerung in weiten teilen politik
wieder eine eigene dass das eine aktive
demokratische entscheidung ist weil es
hier darum geht dass unser aller
lebensalltag davon betroffen ist und wir
können ja nicht millionen leute die eine
petition unterzeichnet oder
hunderttausende die auf die straße gehen
oder e mails an die europaabgeordneten
schicken damit eben ein gesetz auch in
ihrem interesse verabschiedet wird
diffamieren als glaubenskrieger an
dieser stelle das würde ich nicht tun
sondern ich jetzt wirklich um eine
abkehr von einer anmutung gesprochen das
ist also sozusagen wird sehr emotional
gefährlich von beiden sein genau das ist
natürlich ein emotionales thema weil es
uns alle betrifft aber trotzdem wird das
ja auch sehr informierter grundlage
miteinander ausgefochten das sieht man
ja auch wenn man in die e mails hinein
kommt also hier findet ein ganz aktiver
ein eigenes prozess von demokratie statt
das begrüße ich sehr an dieser stelle
und ich glaube man muss halt auch die
bedenken sehr ernst nehmen die in diesen
e-mails oder auf der straße geäußert
werden oder eben die auch durch diese
petition zum ausdruck gebracht worden
sind
die sich natürlich alle sehr fokussieren
und in der tat eben auch immer ein
bisschen den eindruck hinterlassen einer
kampagne
nun könnte man sagen
die antworten die man zum teil von denen
die angegriffen wurden gehört hat waren
auch manchmal ein bisschen sozusagen
über den durst
also ich erinnere eintrete und eine
interviewäußerung vom vergangenen
wochenende die inzwischen relativiert
wurde
ich weiß herr schavan hat abgesprochen
die e mails die man erhalten hat
sie hatten da auch eine
interview-äußerung wenn ich das recht
weiß von google besteuerte fake campagna
ich glaube sie haben das dann später
noch mal ein paar mal erklärt sind wir
da an einem punkt mit politischen
debatte gekommen wo es uns einfach nicht
mehr gut tut und wo wir die sache ein
bisschen aus dem auge verlieren nur
sozusagen um den kampf zu gewinnen
also erstmal finde ich es gut dass sich
viele menschen mit dieser thematik
beschäftigen
und ich finde es auch in ordnung dass
menschen demonstrieren gehen und sagen
wir haben da eine andere meinung als
vielleicht ihr im europaparlament
was ich aber vorurteilen musste das muss
man ja auch noch mal ganz klar sagen ist
die art und weise wie es zum teil
passiert also mir persönlich wurde
gewalt angedroht mir persönlich wurde
angedroht wenn man mich sehen würde
würde man mich zusammen schlagen und so
weiter einem kollegen von mir dem sind
sogar morddrohungen ins haus gegangen
das geht eindeutig zu weit und was wir
haben wir haben kaum noch die
möglichkeit mit argumenten auch trotz
bringen ich selbst hab mich mal geäußert
an einem freitagnachmittag als ich gegen
17 uhr mehrere tausend e-mails zur
gleichen zeit bekommen habe alle mit der
gleichen absender adresse wo ich dann
gesagt habe mensch google habt ihr das
wirklich nötig daraus hat man mir
unterstellt dass sich jeder e-mail unter
stelle die ich bekomme dass das von
einem bot gesteuert ist was definitiv
nicht der fall war
das habe ich relativiert diese
relativierung hat man aber nicht ernst
genommen hat gesagt das interessiert uns
nicht was du jetzt gesagt hat sondern
wir nehmen nur diese eine e mail auf das
gleiche ist jetzt an diesem wochenende
auch wieder passiert also es ist sehr
schwierig da in der argumentation auch
dort zu dringen mit den telefonanrufen
die wir haben damit dem einen oder
anderen habe ich auch telefoniert wenn
man da mal vernünftig diskutiert und
sagt warum das eigentlich machen
dann stoßen wir schon auch verständnis
und jetzt es ist nicht so dass jeder
junge mensch sagt er wir zerstören das
internet nach dem wie man mit dem
gesprochen habe wie man zerstören ja
nicht das internet also das was man uns
da ist einfach nicht die arbeit und
spricht das ist sozusagen die
perspektive sache und das heute noch
niemals in ihrem leben einen lobbyisten
gesehen haben würden sie wahrscheinlich
beides aber auch nicht unterschlagen
oder behaupten wollen wenn wir sozusagen
noch mal auf diese ausformung kommen wir
haben jetzt fast zehn minuten reden
können ohne dass das wort upload filter
was übrigens nicht im text drin ist zu
verwenden aber wenn wir da das müssen
wir noch mal an zwei stellen jetzt kurz
aufgreifen ist es nicht eigentlich so
dass wir irgendeine form von upload
filter die wir so nicht nennen aber
jetzt schon haben so eine art rege
mechanismus dass bestimmte dinge beim
hochladen doch gebremst werden also
entspricht das nicht schon der realität
ja zumindest bei großen plattformen wenn
es um kriminelle inhalte geht oder um
gewalt verherrlichen inhalte ist das der
fall das stimmt aber das ist ja auch
selbstverständlich glaube ich war das
unseren demokratischen grundkonsens
entspricht wir reden ja über in dem
sinne upload väter die verpflichtend
eingeführt werden müssen auch wenn sie
namentlich nicht in der artikel 13
version jetzt enthalten sind
aber es gibt keine andere
technologischen varianten als eben diese
upload filter der zeit wenn der
gesetzestext so bleibt wie er ist
deshalb werde ich im übrigen nachher
auch diesen artikel 13 ablehnen und
dagegen stimmen sowie die upload filter
jetzt konzipiert sind werden sie
natürlich die meinungsfreiheit im netz
an das sind ja die gründe die die leute
eben auch so aktiv werden lassen derzeit
die freiheit im netz einschränken weil
bestimmte und dafür gibt es viele
beispiele das möchte ich nur zum haus
führen dass im rennen geht es nämlich
gleich raus ja das klar es ihm wirklich
beispiel von zum beispiel king sting
seiner band die einer kampagne gefahren
hat das dann die rechte nicht mehr
gefährden können weil upload filter
nicht in der lage sind über collagen
satzung und der zu unterscheiden damit
wird die meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt
und das ist ein reales problem und das
treibt die leute um wir werden heute
echten parlamentarismus erleben so zu
sagen ich weiß nicht ob man das mit ja
nein beantworten keiner schulze aber zum
schluss die union stellt sich für eine
nationale lösung die upload felder
verbietet ist das wirklich realistisch
das wäre dann also das kann man nicht
aber ein paar fragen müssen noch offen
bleiben das macht es spannend für uns
also
wir gehen jetzt rein ins europäische
parlament und der berichterstatter und
sozusagen vater des ganzen werkes
aktienfonds jetzt am pult wie können wir
das anpassen wollen wir unser eigentum
eigentlich noch schützen so wie wir es
kennen und gilt das eigentumsrecht
überhaupt für uns noch oder wem gehört
es wollen wir einen rechtsrahmen für das
internet hier schaffen so dass auch
eigentümer im grunde nicht gestohlen
werden das ist die große frage mit der
wir uns hier heute auseinandersetzen und
inwieweit das abgewogen werden muss
ausbalancieren und werden muss zur
meinungsfreiheit und dem diebstahl vom
eigentum das ist das worum es einfach
geht und wollen wir im internet am ende
alles erlauben oder haben wir noch den
schutz von werten
ich weiß dass sich die ganze diskussion
um den berühmten artikel 13 aufhängt und
sich alles darauf konzentriert möchte
aber dennoch ganz kurz auf position
beziehen zu den anderen inhalten die wir
in dieser richtlinie verankert haben
dass es einmal wir dass wir ein modernes
text und data mining haben ein
kommerzielles text und data mining was
wir dort implementieren was der
fortschrittlich ist und ich glaube auch
weltweit die erste möglichkeit in dieser
richtung
wir haben über den artikel 12 auch hier
eine möglichkeit geschaffen dass das
bgh-urteil repro bell auch hier wieder
für die länder die davon betroffen waren
entsprechend auch wieder in eine
möglichkeit kommen eine balance zu hause
zu schaffen zwei bei den buchautoren und
hinsichtlich der buchverlage
wir haben für die künstler für die
kleinen künstler für schauspieler für
alle kreativen auch hier mit den
artikeln 14 ford folgende alles in der
alten reihung sozusagen 14 ford folgende
hier eine möglichkeit geschaffen
auch ein besseres verhältnis zu den
rechteinhabern produzenten labeln oder
auch verlagen hinzu
ohne dass man auch gleichzeitig immer zu
gericht laufen muss dass es
möglichkeiten gibt hier das verhältnis
entsprechend zu verbessern
wir haben mit artikel 11 eine
möglichkeit dass auch hier unsere
presseverlage ein besseres recht
bekommen und das ist das was wir
grundsätzlich hier machen nämlich ihnen
das recht nur geben wie sie mit dem
recht am ende umgehen bleibt ihnen
überlassen aber sie haben die
möglichkeit hier auf bessere augenhöhe
zu den entsprechenden fälle zu den
plattformen zu kommen weil auch hier im
internet die möglichkeit vor herrscht
und sich das so entwickelt hat in den
letzten jahren dass man einfach das was
im internet erhältlich ist für kostenlos
erachtet und benutzt in einer art und
weise dass eben verlage hieraus kein
erfolg mehr ziehen können wenn wir uns
mal artikel 13 angucken da wird vielfach
versäumt mal darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
eine eigene zugang eine definition
geschaffen haben wo wir nur die
plattformen auch davon unter artikel 13
fallen lassen
die genau wissen dass sie das eigentum
anderer benutzen und hier mit viel geld
machen und letztlich wird daraus eine
frage wie man das eigentlich technisch
umsetzen kann bei plattformen die alle
einladen alles hochzuladen was man
möchte wo auch die plattform eine
verantwortung haben müssen die wir ihnen
heute übertragen wollen
eine verantwortung auch mit dem eigentum
anderer richtig umzugehen und das
eigentum anderer auch zu respektieren
und das ist die frage um die es
eigentlich heute geht wir haben eine
arbeitsfähige eine gute grundlage dafür
geschaffen hier voranzukommen was den
mitgliedsstaaten eine anleitung auch
gibt das ganze entsprechend umzusetzen
und deshalb glaube ich dass das hier der
richtige weg gewesen ist oder der
richtige weg ist um hier voranzukommen
um das aus zu balancieren zwischen
eigentumsrechten meinungsfreiheit und
digitaler welt
dank einer diese vielen dank als
nächstes hat der vertreter des
binnenmarktausschusses und ihre vielen
dank frau präsidentin
ich denke angesichts der digitalen
revolution ist es offensichtlich dass
man reform des urheberrechts brauchen es
geht um prinzipien die wir schon
mehrfach in den letzten jahren hier
erörtert haben vor allen dingen auch die
haftung und verantwortung der das
bombardement über die medien dass wir
heute erleben ist auch daran zu
ausgerichtete dass man versucht hier
einfluss zu nehmen ich denke es geht
nicht um zensur sondern wir wollen die
freiheit des netzes gewähren ist geht ja
auch nicht darum dass gemeinnützige
plattformen wie zum beispiel wikipedia
betroffen sind oder klein oder neu
gegründete es ist einfach so man will
immer offensichtlicher dass das netz
weiterhin ein wilder westen ist und nur
die großen plattformen davon profitieren
die autoren die kreativen sind das
rückgrat unserer gesellschaft und
stellen auch einen wichtigen teil außer
volkswirtschaften gabriel das wort geben
vielen dank frau weil sie denn und
verehrter berichterstatter
schattenbericht starter verehrte
abgeordnete
ich darf mich erst einmal bei ihnen
bedanken für die konstruktiven
aussprache die wir in den letzten jahren
durchgeführt haben die richtlinie ist
ein essentielles element für unsere
strategie des digitalen binnenmarktes in
der kommission haben wir doch mit
zufriedenheit gesehen dass wir uns
professors politisch geeinigt haben zu
diesen sehr wichtigen dossier
es ist aber ein äußerst wichtiger
augenblick auch für die europäische
kultur für die digitalen binnenmarkt und
die verteidigung unserer europäischen
werte
wir glauben dass wir durch unsere
gemeinsamen ziele erreichen und künstler
und autoren schützen unsere europäischen
werte sind ja auch durch künstler
journalisten presse gebildet und gewahrt
geblieben durch filme musik bibliotheken
forscher und viele andere auch die
presse ist ein sektor geschaffen wird
es ist hier wichtig dem bürger unser
kultur immer zugänglich zu machen und
die individuellen kunstschaffenden haben
natürlich hier auch besondere
bestimmungen die ihren
verhandlungsspielraum stärken und ihnen
eine faire entlohnung ermöglichen
all diese menschen bieten auf uns dass
die europäische union ihre versprechen
hält und was unsere kunstschaffenden
angeht sie beleben unsere kultur unsere
journalisten sind das rückgrat unserer
demokratie
wir haben jetzt eine politische einigung
gefunden das ausgewogen und auch
durchaus ehrgeizig die verschiedenen
interessen werden unter einen hut
die rechteinhaber werden fair entlohnt
und die auswirkungen auf die
dienstleister
professionell und die meinungsfreiheit
und die freie meinungsäußerung sind
geschützt ich darf noch erwähnen dass
die kommission eine erklärung
veröffentlichen wird über die situation
der sportveranstalter das wird mit der
richtlinie einhergehen
der text ist in der legislative
entschließung zu finden beziehungsweise
ist ihr angefügt jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf den meinungsaustausch
ich hoffe natürlich dass diese
richtlinie unterstützt werden wird und
wir dadurch ein klares signal abgeben
werden an unsere künstler autoren und
unsere werte dankeschön frau kommissarin
bekommt herr für den ausschuss für
industrie forschung und energie
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin
urheberrecht vielen digitalen märkte ist
erforderlich da hin besteht
weitestgehend einigkeit
wir haben das entwickelte und das was
wir heute haben ist nicht mehr aktuell
denn da gibt es viele rechtslücken und
hier und da ist es sogar ein risiko für
die markt beziehungen von daher muss das
ganze klar geregelt sein das ist aber
noch nicht der fall
die richtlinie versucht somit
manipulieren und die große unternehmen
kämpfen und man sieht dass auf beiden
seiten daher heftig reagiert wird der
digital die genannten seitens der
anderen
niemand hatte wirklich
innovative ideen vorzubringen es ist
sehr überraschend dass es einige
instanzen gibt die direkt von der
richtlinie betroffen sind wie auch die
wissenschaft genutzt haben wo man heute
auf ergebnisse warten
darüber spricht keiner ich glaube wir
sind an einem scheideweg angelangt und
das parlament ist so nicht in der lage
rational zu entscheiden deshalb
demnächst coach nicht vor eine minute
für den kulturausschuss
vielen dank frau präsidentin
ich denke alles wurde ja schon gesagt
dass sie mir liebten dieses textes
angelangt ich mich auch nicht weiter
ausführen mich nur darauf eingehen was
diese abstimmung für europa bedeutet
europa hat immer gesagt ist es an der
spitze der regulierung im gegenteil wir
sind ein modell für die welt und heute
ist die alternative klar entweder wir
bekräftigen unsere führende rolle oder
wer geben sie völlig aus dieser text ist
das ergebnis eines trios ist kein text á
la carte und ich denke ich hier geht es
vor allen dingen darum zu sehen dass
weder die bürger noch die verfassen
die kmu nicht davon profitieren nur die
großen vier plattformen ist es wirklich
gerecht brauchen wir nicht eine welt wo
die autoren geschützt werden und wo die
nutzer auch geschützt und genau das
steht in diesem text und für uns gilt
die frage haften die plattform oder
nicht tragen sie eine verantwortung
gegenüber der gesellschaft diese frage
ist die einzige frage die wir
beantworten müssen als europäer
[Applaus]
minute wieder finden können das internet
ist ja nicht nur eine möglichkeit dinge
1 zu sehen sondern es ist auch ein
kreativer ort wo viele sich
verwirklichen können
finanziell ist es natürlich nicht immer
unproblematisch jetzt muss ich alles
überprüfen ob die lizenzen und vorhanden
sind oder wenn zum beispiel
zusammenstellungen stadt werden dann
maschinen die filtern sollen das
erkennen und nicht was wird passieren
die plattform werde vorsichtig sein
sie werden
da blockieren weil sie nicht selber
entscheiden was akzeptabler inhalt ist
es sehen sich ja bußgeldern
konsequenzen haben glaube ich bin für
eine streichung von artikel 13 ansonsten
ist der bericht sehr sehr gut und ich
danke axel für die sehr harte arbeit
hier getan hatte collex bossy entwurf in
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich war
jetzt in der ersten runde ein bisschen
flexibler aber das wird sich sofort
ändern herzog oder anderthalb minuten
redezeit
sehr geehrte frau vorsitzende sehr
geehrte frau kommissarin
die europäische union braucht ganz
bestimmt eine reform des urheberrechtes
wir suchen eine neue ausgewogenheit ein
neues gleichgewicht zwischen den
interessen der urheber und der
plattformen
wir suchen ein gleichgewicht für das 21
jahrhundert und deshalb freut es mich
dass der entwurf neue ausnahmen von dem
urheberrechtsschutz zugunsten der
bildung der auf bewahrung des
kulturerbes ich freue mich sehr dass
dieser entwurf die rechte der
herausgeber bestätigt der verleger aber
gleichzeitig bereit ist mit den
parasiten an schluss zu machen mit dem
plattformen die urheberrechtlich
geschützten inhalte stehen
wir haben hier gehört dass es jetzt
einer zensur des internets eingeführt
werden solle
aber die zensur des internets würde erst
dann kommen wenn man den talentierten
kreativen künstlern nicht die
möglichkeit schaffen würde sich
professionell zu ernähren von ihrem
talent damit sie ein umfeld zu kreieren
würden wo diese als taxifahrer ihr geld
hätten verdienen müssen und erst nach
ihrer arbeit dann das schreiben können
kreative und das wäre eine zensur des
internets ein ergebnis in diesem entwurf
ist für mich ein erfolg und das freut
mich
vielen dank
letzte frau gehringer die irgendwer
keine minute bitteschön dankeschön in
den letzten zwei jahren haben wir über
verschiedene fassungen von artikel 13
gesprochen jetzt ist sicher dass dieser
texte das heute bekannte internet ändern
wird und enorme negative auswirkungen
auf wilden trabi die menschen das wissen
teilen
aber es geht uns darum die unterstützung
der kreativen der urheber dass wir ein
gleichgewicht bekommen zwischen den
rechten aller beteiligten aber das ist
ein großer fehler
deshalb haben wir nur eine wahl artikel
13 zu streichen das wäre das mindeste
damit das ganze nicht so negativ wird
für die europäischen digital unternehmen
und die bürger denn sie benutzen das und
sie haben auch demonstriert in den
meisten europäischen hauptstadt werten
ein mandat vom europäischen parlament
und der diese geschützte und hatte die
mittelständischen unternehmen von
artikel 13 ausgenommen aber das ist
jetzt leider nicht mehr der fall
deshalb werden sie verpflichtet sein
kostenintensive filter technologie zu
verwenden
von den us amerikanischen digital riesen
verwendet werden so dass er also größte
anstrengungen unternehmen um lizenzen
zukaufen für diejenigen die solche
filter lassen aber das ist möglich die
für residenten unterbricht es tut mir
wirklich leid aber ich habe sie vorher
gewarnt
von daher muss ich sie beim eine blaue
karte von herrn oder aber sie haben ja
redete später vielleicht können sie das
dann dann in dieser zeit und da bringen
wir angehen
herr karim anderthalb minuten bitte
zunächst meine glückwünsche für axel er
hat wirklich tolle arbeit geleistet ich
meine priorität bestand ja immer darin
dass rechteinhaber und kulturschaffende
auch von ihren werken leben kamen und
dass auch ihr recht auf kommunikation
mit der öffentlichkeit geschützt
das ist von entscheidender bedeutung
weil wir jetzt neue geschäftsmodelle und
plattformen haben die
ausgangsvoraussetzungen sind nicht mehr
gleich leicht war die einigung nicht
aber mein ziel wurde erreicht und
insofern werde ich mich für den text
aussprechen weil er in vielen punkten
verbessert wurde also text und daten
mining wird überall in der eu zum ersten
mal möglich sein artikel 11 wurde bei
den verhandlungen verbessert so dass die
zukunft der verlage auch gesichert wird
das recht gilt nur für kleine schnipsel
von texten und einzelne worte und
artikel 13 macht klar dass die plattform
sich nicht mehr auf den safe harbor für
den teehandel rufen könnten sondern sie
müssen auch ein entsprechendes entgelt
zahlen für urheberrechts geschützte
werte haben auch flexibilität für die
mitgliedstaaten eingebaut es ist von
entscheidender bedeutung und es gibt
auch keine allgemeine überwachung der
nutzer
obwohl einige plattformen versucht haben
das den menschen so zu verkaufen das ist
dies information und wir werden uns
dagegen wehren
wir sind hier immer noch wenn sich
gründer aller durch alle fraktionen
werden gleich auch noch eine der großen
gegnerin dieser urheberrechtsreform
hören das ist doch absurd dass hier eine
debatte aus bremsen denn heute schauen
uns alle zu und die leute kommen hierher
und haben ihre reden dabei und wir haben
keine debatte bei so einem wichtigen
thema weil sie das verhindern
ich glaub ich glaube ich dass es reise
oder fair ist sehr schön wenn jeder
redezeit hätte ich weiß natürlich dass
die leute nicht alle auf der liste sind
die heute hier im plenarsaal sind sie
sind auch dass ich versuche dann das in
ketsch iii zu verbessern wenn das länger
dauern soll für einen austausch
meinungsaustausch dann bin ich damit
einverstanden
das war eben der grund für meine
entscheidung aber ich würde das auf
jeden fall vermerken havanna zwei
minuten
vielen dank frau präsident morgen ist
wirklich ein historischer augenblick
denn zum ersten mal ist es auf ein
kontinent so dass eine parlamentarische
versammlung versucht ein gleichgewicht
zu schaffen
ein gleichgewicht der kräfte zwischen
den großen plattformen und denen die sie
lehren die presse die kulturschaffenden
130 milliarden euro
tausende hier in europa arbeiten in
diesem bereich
sie sind bedroht durch die finanziellen
kräfteverhältnisse die herrschen
die presse ist dabei stückweise weg zu
sterben
das muss man aufhalten die presse
verehrte kollegin frau presse ist auch
die grundlage unserer demokratie wenn es
keine freie presse mehr gibt wenn es
keine journalisten mehr gibt in google
wikipedia oder sonstwo dann haben wir
keine informationen mehr sonst haben wir
nur noch gerüchte haben wir ja gesehen
was da zum teil auch in den letzten
monaten aufgetaucht ist der text ist die
einzige chance für die kulturschaffenden
und die presse das gleichgewicht zu
ihren gunsten wiederherzustellen und
ihre zukunft zu sichern und daher müssen
wir für diesen text stimmen und alle
änderungen ablehnen block abstimmen das
ist ja nur ein erster schritt und wir
werden noch andere schritte brauchen um
ihr ein gleichgewicht wiederherzustellen
zensur hat man gesagt filtern wikipedia
wikipedia ist im text geschätzt da
gibt's keine zensuren keine filterung
warum gibt diese ideen jetzt auch hier
im plenarsaal weil zum ersten mal in
meiner mandatszeit sind wir praktisch
von den großen finanzinteressen als
geiseln genommen worden bei unseren
ganzen aktivität man muss und block zu
diesem text abstimmen sonst wird das
große konsequenzen haben also ein
befürworter und jetzt doch eine der
größten gegnerinnen julia riedel von der
deutschen piratenpartei
ich habe schon 12
drei minuten frau räder
drei dinge sind an dieser debatte ums
urheberrecht beispiellos erstens 200.000
menschen haben an diesem wochenende
gegen diese reformen demonstriert 5
millionen haben eine petition gegen
upload filter unterschrieben noch nie
hat es ein
derart breiten protest gegen eine
eu-richtlinie gegeben
2 noch nie wurden proteste von diesem
haus so konsequent ignoriert bereits im
sommer sahen sich wählerinnen und wähler
einer massiven desinformationskampagne
ausgesetzt anstatt sich mit kritik
auseinanderzusetzen wurde jede kritische
stimme mit beleidigungen überzogen
da wurden gerüchte gestreut wie eben vom
kollegen cover da die mails cam von bots
die eu-kommission hat kritikerin als
mord bezeichnet und der
delegationsleiter der cdu herr caspary
sagt sogar demonstranten während
bezahlen
alle diese diffamierungen sind frei
erfunden und leicht widerlegt lanciert
wurden sie von einigen wenigen
lobbygruppen und verbreitet wurden sie
im feuilleton bestimmter zeitungen die
sich von der urheberrechtsreform profite
erhoffen
leider hat diese desinformation
funktioniert heute wo bilder von
massendemonstrationen um die welt geben
glauben manche immer noch die mails kam
nicht von echten menschen
dieser glaube alle kritik sei aus
amerika gesteuert hat sie dagegen
geimpft sich mit den bedenken inhaltlich
auseinanderzusetzen
ganz gleich dass die warnungen vor
upload filter vom
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten kommen vom
un sonderberichterstatter für
meinungsfreiheit und von führenden
forschungszentren
drittens niemand weder die union noch
die spd noch die opposition hält diese
reform für sinnvoll
niemand will die politische
verantwortung übernehmen für upload
fischer die mit artikel 13 kommen
dafür stimmt wird die dafür stimmen wird
die bundesregierung trotzdem bliebe
kollegen ich bitte sie haben alle ihre
zeit ich möchte bitte auch meine rede
halten dürfen dankeschön
[Applaus]
vorsitzende ich warte bis ich die
kollegen beruhigt haben
[Applaus]
frau rheda hamburg bitte frau trainer
spricht
wir sollten die redner respektieren
bitte frau in der bundesregierung will
verantwortung für die upload filter
insel übernehmen nicht einmal kanzlerin
merkel dafür stimmen wird die
bundesregierung trotzdem und seit
gestern wissen wir auch woran das liegen
könnte
denn die faz hat einen kuhhandel
zwischen deutschland und frankreich
aufgedeckt wonach deutschland
anscheinend upload filter akzeptiert im
tausch gegen frankreichs zustimmung zur
nord stream gaspipeline das tragischste
ich freue mich dass sie alle so was sind
heute morgen aber wir sollten doch frau
räder die möglichkeit geben zu sprechen
und zwar beide seiten des hauses herren
das tragische an diesen vorgang ist eine
neue generation die dieses jahr zum
ersten mal zur europawahl geht wer
gleich ihre lektion euro proteste sind
nichts wert die politik wird lügen über
euch aus kippen und sich von
sachargumenten nicht beeindrucken lassen
wenn es um knallharte geopolitische
interessen geht diese erfahrung dieses
gefühl von machtlosigkeit wird sie
nachhaltig prägen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen so können wir nicht politik
machen
diese richtlinie darf nicht ohne
änderung durch kommen das wäre nicht nur
verheerend für die freiheit im netz
es würde auch einer ganzen generation
das vertrauen rauben dass die politik
funktioniert und dass dieses parlament
die interessen der haltung vertritt
deshalb margarita 11 und 13 steigern
dankeschön
[Applaus]
herr caspari hat eine frage nehmen sie
diese anbieter caspari sehr geehrte
kolleginnen rede habe ich sie gerade
richtig verstanden dass sie mir
unterstellt hätten dass ich
demonstranten als gekauft bezeichnet
hätte wenn dem so wäre weil ich habe sie
so verstanden ich möchte ganz klar
klarstellen und wiederholen was ich
gesagt habe und ich bitte nur meine
worte zu nehmen und nicht das was sie
und andere interessierte bewusst dass
interpretieren und fehlinterpretieren
ich habe gesagt nun wird offensichtlich
versucht auch mit gekauften
demonstranten die verabschiedung des
urheberrechts zu verhindern
damit habe ich ausdrücklich nicht die
tausenden jungen menschen gemeint und
die tausende menschen um 12 auf die
straße gehen die funktion gebrauch
machen das wäre das immer verteidigen
aber wenn die freiheit der allgemeinen
zeitung in einem artikel mit über 30
sekunden bekommt man für eine frage sie
haben sich geäußert und jetzt der
fahrräder davon einen 30 sekunden das
sind die vorschriften an die wir uns
halten müssen fahrräder bitte caspari
sie haben es gerade selbst vorgelegen
sie haben gesagt dass einige
demonstranten gekauft waren und sie
haben davon 450 euro geredet ich wir
haben es alles gehört die 450 euro von
denen sie geredet haben hat die
bürgerrechtsorganisation edri ihren
mitgliedern und freiwilligen angeboten
um nach brüssel zu kommen um an lobby
treffen teilzunehmen
genauso tut dass die gema sie glauben
doch nicht wirklich dass wenn zum
beispiel mitglieder der gema nach
brüssel eingeladen werden dass die ihre
reisekosten selbst tragen müssen
das sind keine gekauften demonstrator
ida dankeschön oder wollten sie sich zur
geschäftsordnung melden
[Musik]
also kann ich das mal folgendermaßen
erlösen sie haben gleich eine minute
redezeit möchten sie diese jetzt für
eine frage nutzen
ein wort ohne mikrofon in den kabinen
leider nicht zuhören und sie gestatten
sie mir nicht meine party stellen die
präsidenten doch es ist ja absurd
ich kann sie hören aber ich glaube nicht
die anderen wenn ihre mikrofon war nicht
eingeschaltet
frau räder setzen sie sich doch mal kurz
mal hin also ich versuche dass
diejenigen die heute früh hierher
gekommen sind um eine spontane meldung
abzugeben die möglichkeit bekommen aber
viele zerstörte diese diskussion frau
räder akzeptieren sie eine kurze frage
von herrn rohde und ich hoffe sie
akzeptieren sie haben genau 30 sekunden
ab jetzt zeit bitte danke wollte sie nur
fragen wo ist denn dieser april der
filter ganz konkret im text bitte
antworte ich muss täglich 6 30 uhr steht
plattformen müssen gemeldete inhalte den
upload verhindern
sie können sich zwar um lizenzen bemühen
aber die rechteinhaber müssen ihnen
keine lizenz verteilen und können im
zweifelsfall auf upload filtern bestehen
das steht ganz eindeutig im text
[Applaus]
[Musik]
chris collins liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
jetzt bekommt hermann stahl kattas wort
anderthalb minuten redezeit an ein
finale der fußball- meisterschaft es ist
deine rationeller verhandlung sitzung
des parlaments ich denke dass ich im
namen von uns ansprechen wenn ich sage
dass wir alle eine große erleichterung
verspüren nachdem wir über diesen text
abgestimmt haben und zwar unabhängig von
dem ergebnis
ich bin gegen das artikel 11 und 13 aber
wir haben zwei jahre von harter arbeit
und von harten verhandlungen hinter uns
ich bin mit dem zufrieden mit dem
ergebnis nicht zufrieden und ich werde
meine fraktion empfehlen gegen den
entwurf zu stimmen
wir haben eine einzigartige gelegenheit
versäumt die kreative branche zu
modernisieren wir haben jetzt einen
entwurf auf dem tisch der die zensur des
internets prosit die schikane von
start-ups wert negative auswirkungen auf
die diskussionsforen sowie auf einzelne
nutzer von sozialen netzen haben das
internet so wie wir es heute kennen wird
enden
dazu könnte ich viele konkrete beweise
an denen aber wir haben leider nicht
genügend zeit darüber hinaus bin ich der
meinung dass wenn die kollegen für
diesen entwurf verstehe das wie eine
ohrfeige den tausenden von bürgern geben
die täglich e-mails geschrieben haben
die petition unterzeichnet haben und die
in den straßen demonstriert haben
es wird sich zeigen deshalb immer mehr
bürger gegenüber der eu skeptisch sind
die arroganz der macht und die tatsache
dass er den würden den räten wenden das
ist genau das was wir ändern muss in
vielen dank
vor 42 minuten jetzt herr ja beide
seiten sprechen uns an durch ihren
lobbyisten auf der anderen seite machen
sich viele menschen sorgen über er
internet also sie werden bezahlt bei
kochte sie hat sogar ein taxi gesehen
dass werbung gemacht hat für diese
gesetzesvorlage auf dem weg hier aber
die großen player die haben das geld um
lobbyarbeit zu leisten aber wir liegen
meine wähler mehr am herzen als die
lobbyisten die bezahlt werden um uns das
zu sagen was sie meinen es geht hier um
den schutz der urheber es geht natürlich
auch darum die einfachen menschen zu
schützen aber artikel 11 artikel 13
die tragen nicht zu einer ausgewogenheit
bei das ist illegal
denn die tech unternehmen werden die
bürger so behandelt als seien sie
schuldig bis zum beweis des gegenteils
und viele inhalte werden automatisch
gelöscht und dann wird man versuchen
alle plattformen in europa sozusagen
gleich zu behandeln obwohl das
urheberrecht von einem land anders ist
als in anderen also da begeben wir uns
auf ein minenfeld also legale inhalte
werden dann so behandelt als seien sie
illegal viele von uns glauben an das
europäische projekt aber wenn wir uns
das vk anschauen
da sieht man auch die spannung bleibt
diejenigen die für einen austritt
gestimmt haben sind auch heute weiter
dafür die für den verbleib gestimmt
haben sind auch weiter wenn aber andere
sagen sie haben 216 für 2016 für den
verbleib bestimmt heute wenn sie dagegen
stimmt wegen dieser urheberrechts
regelung sie werden da ein kleiner teil
in die bevölkerung das ist eine
schlechte gesetzgebung klassisches
beispiel für das was man noch mal kurz
vor schluss den
latour periode durchpeitschen will also
wir hatten wochen vorher zeit aber jetzt
versucht man alles noch schnell durch zu
pushen
bitte hört auf ihre wähler hören sie auf
ihren wähler und vergrößern sie nicht
noch die kluft zwischen diesem parlament
und den menschen in europa dem
vereinigten königreich nicht noch größer
als sie schon ist wir haben eine blaue
karte von heskey akzeptieren sie die
hass rojewski bitteschön 30 sekunden
ja ich bin sicher lernen oder einer der
letzten lebenden lobbyisten bezeichnen
kann aber ich möchte schon unterschiede
machen zwischen unterschiedlichen
lobbyisten
es gibt gruppen von menschen die für ihr
recht auf entlohnung kämpfen und die
kann man doch nicht lobbyist nennen also
unterscheiden sie zwischen großen
kommerziellen lobbyisten und den
menschen die allein dafür kämpfen dass
sie eine gerechte entlohnung bekommen
ich überhaupt kein problem damit dass
die leute ihren lebensunterhalt damit
verdienen wollen das sollten sie auch zu
und ich habe auch kein problem mit den
vertretern der öffentlichkeit die sich
äußern aber ich sehe es immer wieder die
industrie brennt uns und nicht die
kreativen was ich von den
kulturschaffenden bei mir zu hause höre
ist nicht das was ich hier wahrnehmen
wir haben natürlich argumente auf beiden
seiten aber die bevölkerung macht sich
große sorgen gerade was die wirkung von
autobild.de anbelangt wir werden uns
heute zu
richtlinie äußern das ist ein
historischer augenblick für europa und
für die kultur es ist das resultat von
gründlicher arbeiten schon seit drei
jahren läuft und jetzt haben sich neue
gräben aufgetan und das alles
orchestriert von den giganten aus
es geht hier aber darum die rechte der
schaffenden und der nutzer ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen
es ist doch viel zu oft so dass die
großen sich von an inhalten einfach
bedienen was ist mit den künstlern sie
haben doch auch ein anrecht auf eine
faire entlohnung auch von diesen
plattformen die immer reicher werden
dank dieser kulturschaffenden ist
einfach so dass sie der macht der großen
nichts entgegenzusetzen und es war noch
nie so war wie heute und dies bringt
jetzt die interessen aller unter einen
hut
dankeschön
derzeit ist es so dass viele firmen im
internet in den sozialen medien
zensieren
auf der grundlage der wünsche der
eigenen eigentümer
wie können wir das legitim als legitim
erachten unsere freiheit so zu
beeinträchtigen
also man kann ja vielleicht einige zur
außen vor lassen nur die nennung meines
namens oder die veröffentlichung meiner
rede hier im europäischen parlament in
einem bestimmten sozialen medien
bestraft den eigentümer der medien für
eine gewisse zeit das sind also
schlechte nachrichten für die freiheit
ist die welt nach über filter führen
begriffe heraus das ist weniger freiheit
das sind wirkliche schwarzl beiden
unserer geschichte da werden wir an die
sowjetunion erinnert also über wollen
wir dachten wir sollten dagegen stimmen
besonders gegen diese vorschrift von
todes wörter letzte redner der ersten
runde jetzt sabine verheyen für die
svp-fraktion neue runde der fraktionen
haben wir hier im parlament und den mit
den mitgliedstaaten gerungen um einen
ausbalancierten kompromiss zu finden und
haben nun endlich einen text der mehr
fairness im internet ermöglicht und
insbesondere die rücksichtslos
kapitalisieren großkonzerne in die
verantwortung nimmt
der schutz auf geistiges eigentum ist
ein grundrecht und wer heute gegen das
urheberrecht stimmt stimmt dafür dass
kunst und kultur wieder zu einer
brotlosen kunst wird 2016 lag das
jährliche medianeinkommen eines
europäischen regisseur und drehbuchautor
bei 19.000 euro
das kann nicht das ziel unserer
gesellschaft und nicht das ziel unserer
politik seien die gleichen politiker
daher vollmundig für mindestlohn für
adäquate einkommen kämpfen ignorieren
hier eine situation wo kapitalistische
großkonzerne kulturschaffende ausbeuten
bis zum gehtnichtmehr
das ziel dieser richtlinie ist nicht das
blocken sondern das lizensieren von
inhalten und damit es keine mammut
aufgabe wird wurde wurden die
lizenzierungs verfahren vereinfacht
dabei wird die meinungsfreiheit unter
anderem in gries alter 70 artikel 17
absatz 7 8 9 und in vielen anderen
bereichen sichergestellt zusätzlich gibt
es viele ausnahmeregelungen
unverhältnismäßige anforderungen
vermeidet zu vermeiden
nichtkommerzielle plattformen und
plattformen wie beispielsweise wikipedia
dropbox ebay sind grundsätzlich von der
richtlinie ausgenommen und auch für
start-ups kleinsten kleinen unternehmen
gelten sonderregeln
und wenn sie aus dem amt aus den
ausnahmen rausfallen gilt immer noch die
professionalität also die
proportionalität der maßnahmen und die
verhältnismäßigkeit die mit
dahintersteht wir bringen fairness ins
internet und plattformen sind diejenigen
die den grössten gewinne abschöpfen
hier müssen wir endlich regeln schaffen
die fairness im internet erlaubt und in
den reinsten kapitalismus den wir hier
immer wieder
neben endlich ein ende setzt für eine
minute vor rossi m bitte wir haben
zweieinhalb jahre intensiv gearbeitet an
diesen text alle kulturschaffen
unterstützen in künstler autoren
journalisten regisseure verlage aber
auch die verbraucher warten auf diesen
text die verbraucher warten auf denn der
text bringt rechtssicherheit und die
willkür der großen wird damit
eingeschränkt es geht darum dass europa
hier auf der disc darum dass private
daten nicht mehr länger so einfach
abgeschöpft werden daten aus unserem
privaten leben aber in diesem fall auch
die arbeiten von künstlern in europa
deshalb wird man akzeptieren dass sie
keine entlohnung mehr bekommen normal
bei uns in einer digitalen welt bewegen
neben aggressive lobbyarbeit
wir erleben bedrohungen die man an uns
richtet finanzierung aus dunklen quellen
steckt hinter einigen plattformen und
ich hoffe dass heute wir uns erheben
gegen den ultra liberalismus der tech
giganten und für eine europäische kultur
vielen dank
in der minute haben wir jetzt eine
auseinandersetzung gehört da ging es
wirklich und das worum es bei dieser
richtlinie geht ist das das größte
problem bei dieser richtung mir ist dass
die interpretation die auslegung ein
monstrum werden
wird es wird schwieriger werden als
alles andere
das ist in der terminologie oft nicht
sehr klar da irgendwelche rechte
einzuräumen für pressehäuser also nur
die größten in der presse werden dann
sowieso auf dem markt bleiben können die
dann die öffentliche meinung auch
beeinflussen können und kleinere werden
da auch nicht mehr mithalten können und
ich würde gegen die bestimmungen der
krise oder eine minute vielen dank
sie hier vielen dank es ist unglaublich
dass wir hier heute die linke hören die
sich vor den karren der tech giganten
spannen lassen
die keine steuern erlassen es gibt
missverständnisse in dieser debatte
es gibt keinen linktext es gibt kein
upload filter egal wie viele fahrräder
das gegenteil behaupte es gibt ein
upload filter denn es gibt keine
beschränkung der rechte des einzelnen
bürgers im gegenteil die verantwortung
obliegt den plattformen und heute
akzeptieren wir ja mit freude dass er in
new delhi das stimmen was auf den
plattformen existieren darf
wir existieren wir akzeptieren keine
technologie aber es geht ja um den
schutz des kunstrasen lichte und
überwachen des einzelnen
das hier ist kunstraub unerhört maßes an
technikern die keine steuern bezahlen
und wir werden wirtschaftlich und auch
geistig armen wenn wir diese richtlinie
nicht positiv durchbringen danke
madame triebel eine minute redezeit und
kollegen
wir wollen ein freies aber auch endlich
faires netz wir wollen freiheit und
verantwortung
wir wollen keine zensur keiner von uns
zensur ist in china da ist aber kein
urheberschutz was wir wollen ist das
aktive kommerzielle plattform endlich
lizensieren müssen alles was lizenziert
wird wird nicht gefiltert
es ist eine win-win-situation was wir
vorschlagen die uploader kriegen
rechtssicherheit es gibt keine
abmahnwellen mehr die plattform müssen
endlich verantwortung übernehmen und die
urheberin und journalistin werden
endlich angemessen bezahlt das nenne ich
eine faire regelung wir bringen
gerechtigkeit ins ins freie netz dass
wir alle wollen wir brauchen generell
regeln für den plattform kapitalismus
die müssen steuern zahlen die müssen
verantwortung übernehmen wenn es
desinformation campaigns gibt wir
brauchen datenschutz den haben wir schon
beschlossen und urheberschutz ist für
mich ein teil eines solchen regelungs
pakets und es geht nicht um
überregulierung es geht einfach um faire
regeln und urheber sind in unserer
gesellschaft eine minderheit sie
brauchen unseren schutz brauchen unsere
förderung bitte stimmen sie für diese
richtlinie ist ist über gerechtigkeit im
internet vielen dank die grüne helga
trüpel nochmal mit einem plädoyer für
diese reform und ihren argumenten mit
hielt eine minute aber eins die
europäische harmonisierung des
urheberrechts begrüßt aber das was jetzt
vorliegt ist alles andere als mutig die
befürworter der reform vor allem verlage
und verwerter sagen die kreativen sind
gestärkt wurden aber fünf millionen
menschen und ich bitte sie das sind auch
kreative haben uns inzwischen per
unterschrift mitgeteilt man überlässt
maschinen keine entscheidungen über
grundrechte
dafür gibt es den rechtsstaat und egal
wie upload filter im artikel 13 oder 17
umschrieben werden kleinere provider
können nicht mit der ganzen welt
lizenzen aushandeln
das ist absurd
die kostspielige filterpflicht bleibt
plattform plattform regulierung sieht
anders aus digital steuer ethische
algorithmen strenges kartellrecht und
deshalb lehnen wir das ergebnis der
trilux ab lasst uns bessere lösungen
finden es geht nicht um marktbereinigung
sondern um freie kommunikation im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert analog und
digital hätten eine minute redezeit ja
das räte gegen faires urheberrecht um
den schutz der legitimen rechte der
urheber aber hier jetzt geht es um den
schutz interesse und multinationaler
unternehmen um die maximierung ihrer
profite
es geht um die kontrolle der
meinungsfreiheit
wenn die medien und das politische
establishment nicht einverstanden sind
da gibt es ja schon viele plattformen
die so genutzt werden und das wird jetzt
institutionalisierte die zensur wird in
signalisierte youtube und andere wollten
eine abstimmung haben über die
geschäftsführung ansonsten wäre das ja
letztes jahr schon durch gegangen aber
die mitglieder sollten sehen das ja
schon in bälde die europa wahlen
anstehen und die wähler sollten genau
schauen wer wie abgestimmt hatte bei
diesen richtlinien texte und sollten
dann gegen diese am 23 mai abstimmen
europäische union und der politik und
medien ist erblich manager wollen
meinungsfreiheit einsetzten und
zensieren wenn die mitglieder des
parlamentes für ihn sind verdienen sie
es auch ihren sitz zu verlieren
eine im juni wählt worden und es mangelt
an regulieren
das internet ist ein beispiel dafür wie
die welt sich entwickeln konnte wenn man
sich einschränkt das internet ist die
letzte bastion der freiheit deshalb
können sie nachts nicht schlafen alles
zeigt dass ihre verordnungen und
richtlinien unnötig sind die welt
stunden bessern da gäbe es sie nicht man
sollte das internet sich einfach
entwickeln lassen wenn diese worte die
zusätzlichen mehrwert wenn wir uns nicht
darum kümmern würden wäre unser leben
einfacher deshalb versuchen sie das
internet zu zerstören und immer auf die
bremse zu treten waren immer das möglich
ist aber wir wollen nicht dass sie auf
die bremse treten
wir wollen vorankommen wir wollen diese
internetfallen nicht wir wollen dass die
kulturschaffende ohne region ihre
arbeiten kann
für eine minute her der grandes 13
versucht einfach nur den plattformen
verantwortung zu geben sie sollen haften
nicht mehr nicht weniger
im internet werden viele urheberrechte
verletzt weil jeder alles hochladen kann
was er will
auch inhalte wie durch das urheberrecht
geschützt
sprich sie sind eigentum eines anderen
das urheberrecht ist genauso ein
eigentumsrecht wie andere
eigentumsrechte wir müssen die werte der
künstler und urheber schützen und das
ganz eindeutig ich denke jetzt müssen
die plattformen nicht der einzelne denn
die plattform profitieren von den ihnen
hatten sie generieren wärme
einnahmen und sie können mit den daten
handeln und ich denke es geht hier darum
dass wir sehen dass das ergebnis des
trios ein positives ist es entspricht
dem ziel das ungleichgewicht zu
beseitigen
das durch die digitale welt entstanden
ist und es verdient unsere unterstützung
für die sozialdemokratische fraktion
timo wirken der deutsche konnte nur
google ist gegen diese reform sagen die
befürworterinnen und befürworter der
richtlinie aber das stimmt nicht dagegen
sind der bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte
der un sonderberichterstatter für
menschenrechte
viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler und auch viele
urheberinnen und urheber diese reform
führt dazu dass verwerter stärker werden
aber nicht kreative die wahrheit ist in
dieser debatte geht es mittlerweile um
viel mehr als um das urheberrecht
es geht um den umgang mit unserer
demokratie 5 millionen menschen die eine
resolution unterschreiben werden von der
kommission als mord bezeichnet
kritische junge menschen werden von den
politischen gegner befürworter der
reform als ferngesteuerte bots und
computerprogramme bezeichnet
demonstrieren der junge menschen werden
und ihn wird unterstellt dass sie ein
demo geld von 450 euro annehmen und nur
deswegen demonstrieren gehen in dieser
debatte geht es um den zustand unserer
demokratie und wir müssen insbesondere
die jungen europäerinnen und europäer
ernst nehmen die arge bedenken mit
dieser reform haben die ihr internet so
wie sie es kennen
tatsächlich zerstören wird liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen gemäß artikel
13 schleichen
[Applaus]
mester werken wie hannah brück hart nein
wir haben eine blaue karte akzeptieren
sie die blaue karte 20 sekunden
ja lieber kollege du hast gerade
aufgezählt wer jetzt alles außer google
noch gegen die reform ist die
justizministerin und spitzenkandidatin
der deutschen sozialdemokratie frau
bella hast du jetzt in der aufzählung
vergessen wie ist denn jetzt ihre
position
sie hat ja im rat dafür gestimmt und
jetzt ruft sie überall auf den
spd-veranstaltung haltet den dieb wir
müssen dagegen stimmen von daher dass
man jetzt nicht so ganz klar und er
hofft mir ist noch ein bisschen
aufklärung von dir wie wird denn es ist
es mir eine ehre die ihr zu helfen
die deutsche bundesjustizministerin
lehnt upload filter ab und musste sich
der bundeskanzlerin geschlagen geben die
einen deal mit der französischen
regierung abgeschlossen hat wie die faz
gestern berichtet hat es gibt den tausch
angeblich und ihr konzept macht sowas ja
nicht einfach so öffentlich gas gegen
absolut filter das ist der grund luca
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es ist ja schon erstaunlich was die faz
da aufgedeckt hat nicht wahr
also ganz augenscheinlich werden dass
sachfremde zusammenhänge hergestellt und
es wird irgendwie ein tauschgeschäft
gemacht zwischen ostring zwei einerseits
und den upload filtern andererseits das
ist glaube ich nicht der stil in dem wir
politik machen sollten wir sollten
sachgerecht fragen brauchen wir denn
tatsächlich dieser upload filter um den
völlig unbestritten urheberrechtsschutz
durchzusetzen
niemand will ja den künstlern ihrer
einnahmen nehmen aber ist es tatsächlich
nötig dass man das mit diesen filtern
macht und wenn dann in diesem hause
behauptet wird dass das gesetz überhaupt
keine filter vorsehe
dann ist das einfach unwahr denn
selbstverständlich steht im gesetz drin
jede plattform muss bevor sie dem ihr
content öffentlich macht erst einmal
überprüfen ob urheberrechte tatsächlich
verletzt werden da durch diese
überprüfung ist eine filterung und
deshalb ist ein upload filter in diesem
gesetz drin
dieser ablauf filter führt aber zum
europa blocking er führt gerade dazu
dass die kleinen künstler die noch
keinen
vertrieb haben noch keinen verleger
haben dass die nicht imstande sein
werden ihren content zu verbreiten
und deshalb ist das wettbewerbsfeindlich
was hier passiert wir sollten artikel 13
streichen aus der urheberrechts linie
und sie ansonsten verabschieden bei der
urheberrechtsschutz als solcher
wichtigsten dankeschön eine minute vor
die tatsache dass diese richtlinie
zweieinhalb jahre gebraucht hat hat sie
auch nicht besser gemacht leider
es hat von ist von akademikern digital
recht an den sonderberichterstatter für
meinungsfreiheit aufgezeigt worden dass
dies wirklich problematisch ist dass
meinungsfreiheit an
jeder hat das recht informationen zu
suchen durch jegliche medien und ohne
grenzen
aber hier werden mit artikel 11
hindernisse aufgestellt
auf dieser suche nach informationen die
rechte der kulturschaffenden müssen
geschützt werden aber kultur schaffen
und rechtehalter sind auch nicht die
gleichen jedenfalls nicht unbedingt hier
bekommt eine kleine gruppe mehr rechte
als der rest
es hat noch im september im letzten
september eine ganze reihe von
alternativen auf dem tisch gegeben jetzt
ist das nicht mehr der fall jetzt kann
man artikel 11 oder 13 uhr entweder
nehmen oder streichen
ich bin für eine streichung der anlass
noch eine minute
dankeschön frau präsidentin
ich möchte diese lächerliche
verschwörungstheorie von der lobby
sprechen der unternehmen dass diejenigen
die ein freies und offenes internet
befürworten bezahlt wurden und von
facebook beeinflussen würden das ist da
einfach quatsch wir haben und ins zeug
legte und zwar seit jahren gegen diese
internetgiganten wir haben uns für
datenschutz
ein gesetz für die privatsphäre der
menschen gegen monopolistische tendenzen
ich möchte sie gerne treffen
google und facebook dort wo es weh tut
dass sie ihre steuern bezahlen
ich trete für eine digital steuer ein
für privatsphäre vorschriften wir wissen
auch dass sie verantwortung übernehmen
für das was sie tun
aber das ist nicht an dieser stelle
richtig glaube ihnen nicht ich vertraue
ihnen nicht google und facebook vertraue
aber den experten die gesagt haben dass
artikel 11 und 13 negativ seien für das
internet und kein kollateralschaden
bedeuten sollten dankeschön für die
grünen das letzte drittel dieser debatte
hier zu erlassen um die
nordamerikanischen giganten zu zwingen
dem kulturschaffen ein gerechtes entgelt
zu zahlen
man versteht natürlich den druck und
auch den hunger der digitalen gigant
denn die europäischen kulturschaffenden
herr kammer da hat ja daran erinnert
haben einen umsatz von über 300
milliarden heute arbeiten mehr im
kultursektor als im bereich automobil
und musste wegen wir hier diskutieren
bei der urheberrechtsrichtlinie und dem
leistungsrecht ist pluralismus die
richtlinie schafft einen ausgewogenen
rechts haben die plattformen müssen
journalisten und kulturschaffende
respektieren gleichzeitig gibt sie alle
rechtssicherheit die es bisher nicht
gibt
alle haben damit zugang zu wissen und
kultur kann sich an neuen in denen wir
sie schützen die inhalte müssen
geschützt werden und nicht deren
kostenloses up shop von vielen dank
[Applaus]
da werde ich ja direktive nadal auf
private vielen dank auf hätte er nicht
diese richtlinie wird zensur einführen
und zwar auf einer ebene die wir nicht
mal in kommunistischen ländern hatten
denn ich glaube hier braucht man gar
nicht mehr offene türen einrennen
aber die bürger europas sie muss man
richten wenn du nicht den rest eure
freiheit verlieren volt müsstet ihr
eigentlich eure regierung und zwingen
die europäische union zu verlassen und
sich an bringt inspirieren
diese diese bürokratische monster sollte
man verlassen
das bürokratische monster europäische
union wir sollten eine wirkliche union
schaffen eine union der nationen eine
innovative sich erneuernde union
man sollte gegen die stimmen die hier
dafür stellen ergibt eine blaue karte
nehmen sie die von herrn frage
akzeptiere es gegen die richtlinie und
gegen die entlohnung von
kulturschaffenden aber für den exit die
sind ja parteiführer einer solchen
partei deren hauptziel es ist polen aus
der eu zu führen
wir haben noch eine blaue karte und die
fassen wir vielleicht zusammen kanada
ganz gut
also er ist vollkommen überzeugt dass
man aus der europäischen union austreten
sollte wann kommt er denn dann hierher
wenn das so listen kommen hier doch mal
her vielleicht schon monat her dass ich
mal hier war aber ich bin einfach dafür
dass länder aus der europäischen union
austreten um eine neue union zu gründen
nicht dieses bürokratische ungetüm und
ich verstehe die frage gar nicht
ich kämpfe dafür in polen dass das
passiert unser austritt wenn ich hier
bin dann vertrete ich natürlich meine
meinung wenn die eu sich nicht verändert
das gehalt gehen und wenn man sich diese
richtlinien sehen was da passiert und
was mit anderen richtlinien so passiert
ist die verabschiedet von sind ja da
zeigt sich doch dass ich hier gar nichts
verändert und das verändert auch nicht
meine meinung wir müssen einfach raus
und neu anfangen
denn die union wie sie es ist ein
ungetüm ja das war eine antwort auf eine
frage aber die andere
wir haben jetzt aber keine zeit
verlieren dankeschön frau präsidentin
zunächst einmal möchte ich mich bedanken
und zwar bei kollege axel bosse diese
hervorragende arbeit die er bis heute
geleistet hat denn ich denke das ist
eine der wichtigsten kämpfe hier in der
jetzigen legislaturperiode die er zu
ende geht denn es geht um die kreative
ideen täten das ist arbeite und künste
europa und deshalb ist sie so doofe
eintreten und deshalb lieben die
europäer europa weil wir genau das alles
verteidigen und die kollegen die gegen
diese richtlinie sind sollten noch
einmal einzeln überdenken wenn die
internet-plattformen milliarden dollar
kassieren wollen über die werbung müssen
sie doch auch den wert der arbeit der
werke anerkennen denn wer kassiert denn
sonst außer ihm vielleicht hier gibt es
ja in google werbung war aber dann würde
das ganze demokratisch laufende
fahrräder
sie haben über junge leute gesprochen
aber bei diesen jungen leuten sind
jungen und mädchen die drei dollar
zahlen für den hervorragenden
journalismus den wir tätigen genau weil
sie die plattform sie nicht bezahlte
denn wenn die dafür eintreten wollen für
diese menschen dann sollten sie für das
copyright eintreten eine minute hat
jetzt grammatik ist das wort schlacht
100 intellektuelle und geistige eigentum
begann als eine diskussion aber hat sich
jetzt verwandelt in eine schlacht um die
seele europas und seiner kultur
es geht darum dass angebote auch im
digitalen
walter überleben ich denke es ist
wichtig dass die eu den mut hat hier die
großen technologiegiganten
herauszufahren
die haben ja die möglichkeit die bürger
irre zu führen
es erstaunt mich dass einige kollegen
das überhaupt immer noch nicht verstehen
auch nach zweieinhalb jahren
verhandlungen und diskussionen und fünf
abstimmung im plenum
jetzt liegt uns das bestmögliche
ergebnis vor und es ist eigentlich doch
sehr bedeutsam dass die richtlinie von
allen offiziellen gremien unterstützt
wird und auch von den künstlern und ich
werde zusammen mit dem berichterstatter
alle kollegen klingen auf die für ein
offenes preis und faires internet sind
das ergebnis des dialogs zu unterstützen
ist es gut für die zukunft europas
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen und
das ist gut für unser aller zukunft
vielen dank dieser richtlinie über her
bereich bzw
dieser entwurf beeinträchtigt die die
freiheit im internet vor allem die
artikel 11 und 13
und deswegen haben wir auch vor kurzem
die wikipedia ausgeschaltet gehabt nach
artikel unter urheberrecht fallen außer
ganz kurzen abschnitten als es leider
nicht festgestellt was es bedeutet sind
es drei bieter oder drei sätze hatte 13
führt die verantwortung der betreiber
eine beliebe betreiber der sozialen
netzwerke oder plattformen dass die
inhalte nicht gestohlen sind das wäre
als
auf einem parkplatz betreiber dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden würde das
die autos wieder abgestellt das sind
nicht gestohlen sind mehr als fünf
millionen menschen haben die petition
gegen diese native unterzeichnet das ist
mehr als sich für die zeit änderung
geäußert haben deswegen bin ich
überrascht ist der rat und die
kommission den willen der wähler
ignorieren wie sie den printmedien
unterlegen sind
ich habe den antrag zusammen mit einer
gruppe abgeordneten eingereicht das
artikel und 13 gelöst werden sollen aber
ich werde trotzdem für die richter
stimmten dann alle haben doch das recht
und ist frei zu äußern im internet und
auch schutzrecht gibt es unabhängiger
journalismus kulturelle werke das ist
noch die grundlagen unserer gesellschaft
und diese debatte scheint jetzt auch zu
zeigen dass diese rechte sich
widersprechen aber das stimmt nicht axel
voss arbeitet doch jetzt ganz
ausgezeichnet seit zweieinhalb jahren
und wir haben eben die großen
plattformen die kräftig geld verdienen
und die diese profite den autoren und
kulturschaffenden gar nicht weitergeben
wenn wir unabhängigen journalismus
wollen unabhängigkeit bestehen bleiben
soll dann müssen wir für die richtige
stimmung
wir hatten natürlich sowieso schon
probleme mit den großen plattformen aber
wir sind doch hier um die
kulturschaffenden zu verteidigen
meine damen und herren sie haben gesehen
das gelbe schild mit dem rest usa im
deutschen bundestag wäre das
möglicherweise schon sozusagen grund für
einen ordnungsruf gewesen aber mit
beginners die vizepräsident des
europäischen parlaments ist auch ein
paar kulant in diesem punkt holland ist
sie nicht was die zeiten angeht sie
führt das sehr straff durch die
schöpfung zu unterstützen das
kulturschaffen und das können wir nur
tun wenn wir eine gerechte entlohnung
vor sehen
diese richtlinie dieser texte ist
ausgewogener weil wir damit auch die
wertschöpfungskette entsprechend
berücksichtigt und ich verstehe nicht
weshalb einige vertreter der linken
einmal sich einsetzen für urheberrecht
aber auf der anderen seite dagegen sind
dass wir den großen plattformen
auferlegen lizenzen zu erwerben das ist
keine überwachung ist es auch keine
gefährdung sondern diese richtlinie
entspricht den herausforderungen des 21
jahrhunderts unter 1 wird dadurch
gestärkt nämlich die redefreiheit die
meinungsfreiheit die freiheit des
kulturschaffens und gerechte entlohnung
für seine arme blanco lópez ich habe
jetzt zwei blaue karten akzeptieren sie
die maden fragen der blauen karte herbig
rübig 30 sekunden dank ich wollte ja ein
blanco lópez sei gleich nur fragen ob es
stimmt dass alle nicht gewerblichen
nutzer in zukunft von der haftung
befreit sind wenn sie ab und downloaden
nada matthias matheis
ja danke schön frau präsidentin ich
möchte den kollegen mal fragen sie haben
ja gesagt es gebe keine schöpfung von
werken wenn sie nicht entsprechend
vergütet werden
sagen sie doch mal wo das steht in der
richtlinie wo in der richtlinie städte
dass es dann eine angemessene vergütung
gibt der kreativen ich hab das nicht
gefunden denn so gibt es aber hier steht
es nirgendwo das ist eine angemessene
familie mit sagen sie da bitte an
welcher stelle das genau steht danke es
geht darum die wertschöpfungskette ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen den großen
plattformen müssen ihren betrachten
leisten
sie müssen die kulturschaffenden gerecht
entlohnen man muss den wert des
kulturschaffens entsprechend belohnen
und insofern verstehe ich die stimme der
linken nicht sie sprechen für einige
wenige und sind zum schaden der arbeit
der kulturschaffenden in unserem lande
und in europa ich bin mir jetzt nicht
sicher ob sie die fahrerin übliche
beantwortet haben herr blancho bisher
üblich hatte da auch noch der frage
wollen sie die beantworten
er hat die frage doch schon gestellt die
frage wurde schon hilft schnell können
sich noch an die frage erinnern
vielleicht können sie nochmal genau an
ich wollte am blanco lópez fragen ob es
stimmt dass alle nicht gewerblichen
nutzer von der haftung dadurch befreit
sind und dass das deshalb die klage
industrie normale bürgerinnen und
bürgern nicht mehr klagen kann auf
verletzung des urheberrechts sondern
dass das in zukunft ausschließlich in
der haftung der dem entsprechenden
plattformen sich befindet
nein ich glaube nicht dass das so ist
nächster redner hab ich denke das ist
ein ausgewogener text der die interessen
aller beteiligten berücksichtigt für die
welt des sport es ist eine enttäuschung
weil die rechte der sportveranstalter
hier nicht berücksichtigt werden
ursprüngliche gab es ja schon september
bei der abstimmung im plenum fast 400
stimmen die für einen entsprechenden
änderungsantrag gestimmt haben wir haben
ja auch dieses urteil für die premier
league und die kommission hatte ja
damals zugesagt die entsprechenden
schutzsysteme zu prüfen
aber die kommission hat sich dazu
entschieden und allgemeine erklärung
abzugeben
natürlich ist es wichtig die rechte der
kultur schaffen zu schützen aber auch
die rechte der sportveranstalter müssen
geschützt werden natürlich werde ich für
diesen text stimmen erscheint mehr
unerlässlich die rechte der
kulturscheune in europa zu schützen
[Applaus]
dankeschön
die debatte zeigt hier die leben
lebendigen leidenschaftlichen
parlamentarismus wir sehen uns nicht
einig bei vielen dingen aber auf alle
fälle glaube ich es in diesem saal heute
niemandem langweilig geworden
das urheberrecht ist nicht mehr
zeitgemäß da sind wir uns einig
internetgiganten verdienen und viele
künstlerinnen und künstler sie nichts
davon
gerade die nicht groß verdienen die
nicht hits am laufenden band produzieren
die nicht irgendwelche top bestseller
schreiben
die brauchen entsprechend dass wir
entsprechende lösungen finden weil die
leben immer prekärer
wir müssen das internet entsprechend wir
dürfen es nicht zerstören aber wir
müssen das urheberrecht an das internet
anpassen
ich bin dagegen dass private internet
konzern auf kosten der informations und
meinungsfreiheit aller die rechte von
kreativen von künstler und künstlerinnen
durchsetzen sollen und dass
das konzept einer umfassenden haftung
der plattform führt zu upload litern und
diese unausweichlich zur zensur im
internet
mein anliegen in diesen ganzen prozess
war und ist es immer gerade die
kreativen besonders zu schützen
die sollen ein entsprechendes recht
haben dass sie eine angemessene und
faire vergütung bekommen
und insofern bin ich absolut enttäuscht
mit dem ergebnis im verhältnis zu dem
was wir im rechtsausschuss abgestimmt
hatten übrigen redner war die letzte
rednerin nationalrat in in dieser
debatte was wir jetzt noch haben bevor
der kommissionsvertreter und nochmal
axel versprechen dass ich kein verfahren
dafür mal fünf minuten also ohne
anmeldung fragen denn wir stehen einer
großen kampagne entgegen
ich werde dafür diese richtlinie stimmen
denn ich denke mal dass diese
überarbeitete fassung sehr gut die
interessen ausweg zwischen den
plattformen und zwischen den
herausgebern verlegern autoren und uns
verbrauchern es die nichtgewerblichen
plattformen sind ausgenommen und auch
die bildungsplattform in artikel 13 weg
die größten emotionen und wurde zum
symbol gegen die sogenannte zensur
die kritiker haben allerdings keinen
konstruktiven vorschlag vorgelegt wie
man sonst die urheber vergüten soll
wie soll man verhindern dass die urheber
um ihre werke bestimmen werden es geht
nicht nur um die autoren um helfer um
die urheber es geht auch um uns um uns
konsumenten deswegen werde ich dafür
stimmen damit eine blaue karte von frau
konnte normalerweise machen wir das
nicht bei den spontanen wortmeldungen
aber jetzt mache ich eine ausnahme
frauke netz kann ja danke danke ich
möchte frau kollegen fragen wenn sie
über die anti kampagne redet wie kommen
sie sich vor wenn sie sehen dass einige
vertreter der tschechischen verleger uns
betrogen dass sie hoffen dass die
journalisten alles dafür tun werden dass
diejenigen die dafür stimmen werden
gegen die an sich der herausgeber werden
sie zum stopp stand kommen impress
medien was ist das denn für eine
kampagne wenn sie über eine anti
kampagne sprechen
es ist eine erpressung nicht weniger
nichts mehr
und das sollen wir sein die wir die nur
eine andere meinung haben
ich möchte sagen dass das was ich an der
ganzen diskussion schätze ist die
offenheit die transparenz und letzten
endes auch die demokratie wir wollten
sie die beiden demokratische
entscheidungen treffen wenn sie sich
erpressen lassen ist das ihre sache ich
war es wichtig erpressen kampagne ist
kampagne
es ist es obliegt uns die argumente
abzuwägen und eine gerechte lösung zu
finden zwischen autoren zwischen
konsumenten lassen wir uns nicht
manipulieren
verteidigen wir argumentieren wir uns
stimmen sollten wir auch zu einem
verhältnis müssen den gerechten schluss
kommen ja auch ausführungen ist aber man
kann jetzt nicht sagen dass das
europäische parlament nicht versucht hat
die grundrechte und auf die rechte der
urheber zu schützen
es geht um die kulturschaffenden während
freiheit lehrern statt funkel der
spanischen verfassung steht es so auch
in der charta der grundrechte und wir
versuchen die schutzbedürftigsten
schützen und in der wertschöpfungskette
sind die kulturschaffenden das
schwächere geht die großen plattformen
die handeln mit unseren daten die zahlen
aber ihre steuern nicht die organisieren
massive tron kampagnen um das
europäische parlament und seiner
abgeordneten zu erpressen
die gute nachricht ist
dass nach dieser richtlinie das internet
weiter bestehen wird aber dass die
beteiligten besser geschützt werden
die für die präsidentin unterbricht sie
haben nur eine minute
ich verstehe dass die großen internet
giganten google facebook apple und so
weiter wie sie alle heißen wegen diesen
richtigen antwort senden
denn dadurch werden ihre gewinne
natürliche bedrohte die sie über jahre
eingefahren haben in europa dadurch das
gratis kostenlose inhalte angeboten
wurden von europäischen urhebern ich
kann das nachvollziehen dass paul julia
räder dagegen ist wenn sie ist für ist
die allgemeine handhabung der piraterie
und das heißt er ja nicht umsonst der
piratenpartei also eine partei die gegen
die urheberrechte erste ich kann das
nachvollziehen dass einige der rechten
auch gegen diese wickeln sind aus
offensichtlichen gründen weil die gegen
die europäische union sind also die
rechtextremen aber ich kann nicht
verstehen dass die nationale kultur die
europäische kultur verteilt ich gern
hier gegen diesen richtlinien sind
das kann ich nicht verstehen wie menthol
ob es das ist ein kampf der giganten und
es hat nichts zu tun mit den interessen
der großen oder der kleinen sondern hier
geht es um die verteilung von inhalten
ohne dass die kulturschaffenden gerecht
entlohnt werden das ist ungleich halt
und free caritas für die betroffenen
es gefährdet die pressefreiheit
das kulturschaffen und es ist immer
weiter monopole und konzentrationen im
digitalen bereich geben
wir hatten vorschläge vorgelegt die den
kulturschaffenden und journalisten und
der presse die möglichkeit leben von
ihrem werk und zu leben
das ist wichtig für die kultur europas
und die pressefreiheit natürlich ist es
nötig dass inhalte frei zirkulieren
können ohne fehlte aber es ist eben so
dass die großen riesen gewinne einfahren
und das auf kosten der kulturschaffenden
danke an user können klinsmann ist
diese urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist nicht
perfekt aber das ergebnis eines
kompromisses und viele jahre von
behandlung ich möchte mich bei axel voss
herzlich bedanken für seine arbeiten mit
allen dieser konflikte es ist wichtig
dass wir die rechte der urheber schützen
vielleicht könnten sie noch mal beginn
schauen wir ob die technik dann
funktioniert frau präsidentin diese
urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist sicherlich
nicht perfekt ist sie auch seiten sodass
wir perfekte gesetz erlassen habe es das
ergebnis von fünf jahren arbeit und
eines kompromisses und man dank axel
voss und allen die an dieser arbeit
beteiligt waren
wir müssen die rechte der produzenten
und der kulturschaffenden auch im
digitalen zeitalter schüttet es ist ein
gutes prinzip auch in der digitalen welt
ist es wichtig versehen dass die urheber
richtlinie kein verstoß gegen
meinungsfreiheit ist sie bedeutet auch
kein blocken von inhalten
es bedeutet einfach dass die
netzwerkplattformen die kommerziell die
werke der urheber vertreiben
entsprechend auch zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden sie brauchten dann der
lizenz und das ist ein gutes prinzip
procap hat als nächstes
schön fragt dankeschön frau präsidentin
zwei gründe warum wir diese richtlinie
nicht zustimmen sollten zunächst einmal
start ups sind nicht wirklich
ausgenommen und werden nach drei jahren
gezwungen filter der großen unternehmen
zu übernehmen
das ist ein wunderbares geschäftsmodell
für die großen amerikanischen
unternehmen und das ist wohl nicht das
was wir uns wünschen können
nicht einmal das wofür die richtlinie
eigentlich vorgesehen ist er der
eigentliche zweck der richtlinie die
gemessen angemessene vergütung von
autoren und künstlern zu erzielen
gewährleistet sie denn diese rechte
werden in den erwägungsgrund total
verwässert und ich denke das ist nicht
das was wir haben wollen sondern wir
wollen starke rechte für die kreativen
und diese werden hier nicht
gewährleistet denn nur diejenigen die
für verlage arbeiten sind in dem schutz
und all die anderen die ganz frei
arbeiten die haben diesen schutz nicht
und das ist glaube ich genau das falsche
[Applaus]
paul costa als letzte rednerin jetzt bei
den spontanen wortmeldung bitteschön
ja danke schön frau präsidentin wir
europäer sollten doch ärgert sich sein
mit diesen richtlinien sollten der welt
zeigen dass auch bei digitalen systeme
nicht die rechte von personen verletzen
kann und die arbeit nicht bezahlt wird
man sollte in kompetenzen und
professionalität in der sender die
einschüchterungskampagne gegen die
europäischen personen sind inakzeptabel
heute versucht man die kommerziellen
interessen zu schützen
schauen wir uns die großen digitalen
unternehmen an die das ganze über
werbung finanzieren
aber die urheber werden nicht angemessen
vergütet wir müssen den großen
plattformen aus dem silicon
all das erklären mit meinungsfreiheit
und ähnliche konzepte die präsidentin
dafür die rednerin bitten doch in
normaler rede geschwindigkeit ihren text
zu verlesen
wenn sie das münchen den text lernt hier
jemandem dem aktivisten kann sie nicht
hören was haben sie gesagt ich habe sie
nicht gehört sie haben 15 sekunden ja
genau das ist mein problem das ist
nämlich zu kurz ich sagte also für uns
geht es um den schutz der kulturellen
vielfalt die intellektuelle tätigkeit
es geht um die professionelle arbeit von
journalisten millionen von
arbeitsplätzen hängen davon ab in der
musiker im journalismus und überall es
geht um das überleben des freien
profunden journalismus aber wir wollen
die kultur nicht knebeln sondern wir
wollen um liga tores ausnahmen haben für
ganz europa für diejenigen in der keine
kommerziellen zwecke verfolgt dankeschön
was wollten sie sie waren nicht auf
meiner liste
ich gebe dann ihnen das wort und noch
jemand von der spd
ich verfolgte sind so viele
ich guck mal wie wir im zeitplan liegen
das ist natürlich eine sehr sehr
wichtige debatte für die kollegen
mikrofon funktioniert nicht einfach hier
vielen dank warum gibt es diese
richtlinie nicht weil die leute
schwierigkeiten haben kulturelle inhalte
zu sehen sondern weil die dieser inhalte
schaffen nicht fair entlohnt werden
man bedient sich ihre inhalte ohne
irgendeine kontrolle und es gibt ja
gesetzgebung die urheberrechte schützt
und die werden hier einfach in gang
im journalismus ist es genau das gleiche
und daran müssen wir denken wenn zb
texte musik oder bilder genutzt werden
die kulturschaffenden haben das recht
ihr werk ihre werke entlohnt zu bekommen
der digitale raum kann kein recht lose
raum sein
es ist leider so gewesen dass die bürger
manipuliert wurden in dieser sache wird
unterbrochen
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
kommissar frau kommissarin aus der
heutigen debatte kann man es klar
entziehen dass wir wirklich dass
internet regeln müssen
es gibt verschiedene meinungen sogar
innerhalb einer fraktion
wir sind davon ausgegangen dass wir die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit garantieren
solchen aber gleichzeitig sollten wir
die autorin und die künstler schützen
und das entgelt sichern wir brauchen
einen digitalen markt aber wir brauchen
auch eine kreative industrie ohne kultur
geht es nicht und die menschen die dort
agieren sollten auch entgelt bekommen
klar es ist nicht ideal artikel 11 13 14
das ist alles problematisch aber wir
haben viel darüber gesprochen ich denke
aber dass wir darüber abstimmen sollten
damit wir einen schritt voran tun und
damit wir diese richtlinie auch
weiterhin verbessern können aber wenn
wir nichts tun und keinen schritt tun
dann werden wir nichts für den digitalen
markt tun für den urheberrecht der für
den schutz der urheber und keinen gewinn
haben dabei
deswegen würde ich dazu hatten dass
diese artikel auch abgestimmt werden
vielen dank
ich versuche das wort zu geben
das ist das dritte mal dass ich mich im
plenum zur urheberrechts wichtigen aus
erst einmal war ich für zurückverweisung
bzw
rückkehr zur ursprünglichen kommission
stansted die urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist
notwendig deren überarbeitung um den
kultur schafften eine gerechte
entlohnung zu ermöglichen die lobbyisten
versuchen hier aufwandes einfluss zu
nehmen um ihre vorteils position von
anbeginn des internet es beizubehalten
und ich denke wir können einfach nicht
zulassen dass der unbegrenzte warm des
internets begrenzt wird hier geht der
bereich um zensur das sieht auch die
reform nicht vor sondern es geht um die
haftung der online-plattformen vielen
dank hier bitte präsident ich weiß wir
sind am schluss fast dieser ausbau der
sehr kontrovers ist nicht nur weil es
unterschiedliche auffassungen gibt das
ist gut so was in einer debatte sondern
weil es merkwürdig ist wir haben müssen
hier die legitimen markt regeln
allerdings sprechen sehr viele hier mit
großer leidenschaft aber was wir
aufstößt ist freundes es gibt im
augenblick eine verzerrung in digitalen
binnenmarkt und wir wollen hier die
rechte der urheber regeln und ich denke
der text ist wirklich sehr ausgewogen
deshalb sind wir gegen eine regulierung
regulierung bedeutet doch nicht verboten
ein
es geht darum dass wir enormen setzender
metalle in diesem markt den digitalen
markt wie auch im finanzmarkt wissen wie
die spielregeln aussehen um mehr geht es
nicht und insofern haben wir auch diese
richtlinie befürwortet frau wird als
nächstes wird
ich mich als die sprecherin für die
labour-partei über kultur in der eu ich
habe im kultursektor gearbeitet habe
einigen kleinen unternehmen gegründet in
diesem bereich und dies ist die größte
reform seit 15 jahren und die macht der
großen über den online inhalt wird
gebremst auch bei nachrichten im
internet es wird dafür sorgen dass
kunstschaffende fair entlohnt werden
ein lied muss 50 millionen mal auf
youtube laufen bevor der künstler
überhaupt einen mindestlohn erhält und
das copyright dafür sorgen dass all
diese kulturschaffenden entlohnt werden
für ihre arbeit ist belohnt kreativität
und stimuliert investitionen im
kultursektor ich darf mich bedanken wird
unterbrochen
jetzt der vizepräsident der eu
kommission und kommissar für digitale
wirtschaft andrus ansip dafür den
mitgliedern des parlamentes danken für
die heutige aussprache fehler redner
haben über upload filter heute
besprochen
eins muss man doch ganz klar sagen
diese finden keine erwähnung in der
richtlinie aber wir wissen ja alle dass
sie bereits eingesetzt werden von großen
plattformen
wenn man gegen die richtlinie stimmte
bedeutet das nicht dass die upload
filter verschwinden
ganz im gegenteil die richtlinie wird
bürgern die möglichkeit geben wieder
einiges erreichen was sie uploaden
könnten das ist auf jeden fall eine
eindeutige verbesserung angesichts der
heutigen situation
die abstimmung über die
urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist behandelt
die nachricht an die kreativen europas
wir machen uns gedanken über sie wir
wollen ihre werte schützen und ihre
beiträge zu unserer kultur schützen
die kultur ist das worauf sich die
europäischen gesellschaft stützen
das ist die quelle unserer werte und
unserer inspirationen die letzten endes
werden ja die europäischen bürger
nutznießer von dieser richtlinie seien
aber rechtliche bessere möglichkeiten
schützen die waage die unterhaltung und
die arbeit von journalisten bei dieser
abstimmung heute geht es auch um die
möglichkeit und fähigkeit der
europäischen union wichtige komplexe
herausforderungen anzunehmen angesichts
der digitalen welt und ist klar das ist
unterschiedliche auffassung gelebte
unterschiedliche stimmen
das ist ganz normal bei einer solchen
wichtigen debatte wir haben die
verschiedenen auffassungen vernommen und
wollen sie alle respektieren aber wir
glauben dass der texte all das trio
ergebnisse ausgewogen ist und das ziel
verfolgte europäisches urheberrecht zu
schützen
nun muss man sich an die arbeit machen
und musste dafür sorgen dass das
urheberrecht auch dem digitalen
zeitalter entspricht
dankeschön frau präsidentin herr forster
und schatten berichterstatter dankeschön
verehrte mitglieder des europäischen
parlamentes
vielen dank zum abschluss jetzt nochmal
axel voss der berichterstatter von der
vp fraktion auch bei manchen beiträgen
heute in der heutigen debatte ist wieder
zu sehen dass eigentlich maß und mitte
dieser debatte irgendwie verloren
gegangen ist mit dieser reform wird es
keine zensur geben mit dieser reform
wird es keine oder oder wird die
rechtmäßige meinungsfreiheit eben nicht
eingeschränkt mit dieser reform schaffen
wir rechtssicherheit für den
rechtmäßigen umgang mit urheberrechtlich
geschützten werken und bieten viel mehr
möglichkeiten für die einzelnen nutzer
und die bürgerinnen und bürger google
facebook youtube machen hier eine
governance bei shitstorm sie verbreiten
desinformationen setzen viel geld ein um
die öffentliche meinung zu erschleichen
sie zeigen wie einfach es ist gerade
jüngere bevölkerungsgruppen zu
instrumentalisieren oder
instrumentalisieren zu lassen und
deshalb geht es heute eben auch darum ob
sich ein parlament und unsere demokratie
heute überhaupt noch gegen mächtige
plattformen durchsetzen kann
es geht um rechtsstaatlichkeit es geht
um den schutz eines grundrechtes um das
wir hier sprechen
es geht um das eigentum es geht um das
recht auf geistiges eigentum und es geht
letztlich eben auch um eine faire
vergütung für die urheber
es liegt heute in unserer hand
europäisches kulturgut zu retten und es
eben nicht der ausbeutung von teck
monopolisten zu überlassen
es liegt heute auch in unserer hand
unseren europäischen kreativen den
dringend benötigten schutz zu bieten und
deshalb bitte ich sie alle unterstützen
sie deshalb den heutigen vorschlag für
eine ausgewogene reform vielen dank
[Applaus]
und das war zum abschluss eine wirklich
bemerkenswerten debatte hier im
europäischen parlament in straßburg
axel förster berichterstatter des
parlaments für diese besondere frage die
eu urheberrechtsreform er hat seine mit
abgeordneten noch mal aufgerufen
trotz alldem was es an öffentlicher
begleitmusik gibt sich auf die stärke
des europäischen parlaments zu besinnen
und tatsächlich dann so zu votieren
wsa im sinne auch dieses parlamentes und
seiner stärke liegt es geht um die
komplizierte frage der balance zwischen
freiheit und regulierung es geht auch um
rechtssicherheit zweieinhalb jahre
dieser prozess um sozusagen ein
kompromiss zu finden und der begriff
trilog den sie hier und da gehört und
gelesen haben bedeutet dass tatsächlich
mehrere parteien nicht parteien im
klassischen sinne beteiligt waren
sondern das europäische parlament auf
der einen seite die europäische
kommission als der anstoßpunkt für das
ganze und eben die regierungen der immer
noch 28 staaten der europäischen union
das alles zusammen in dieser reform
gegen 13 uhr erwarten wir die
abstimmungen dazu es gibt diverse
änderungsanträge fakt ist wenn diese
reform als ganzes scheitern sollte dann
wäre es tatsächlich für eine längere
zeit weil sie wissen auch ende mai haben
wir die nächsten europaparlament und bis
dato würde sozusagen keine alternative
variante greifen es wird also in der tat
recht spannend wir bei phoenix halten
sie dazu auf dem laufenden
allerdings gibt es sehr viele andere
themen die unser interesse und ihr
interesse erfordern sollten
und dazu können jetzt sehr viel mehr
sagen mein kollege stephan kohler in
bonn